العربيه تعود مجددا لمدينه بيلجرد بعد نصف
عام تقريبا والمشهد هنا تغير بالكامل
هدوء مركز المدينه يشي بالترقب الحذر اذ
اصبح الوضع في باقي مناطق الاقليم
الجنوبيه والغربيه يعيش حاله حرب حقيقيه
وصفها خبراء بالاشد عنفا منذ اندلاعي
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
الوضع خطير للغايه مع غياب اجهزه الانذار
المتطوره التنبيه من الضربات ياتي بعد
حدوثها وهذا خطر خاصه ان المنازل متلاصقه
القصف لا يطال مركز مدينه الوضع مقلق بحيث
قد تطالون الضربات ونحن لا نعلم بها اتمنى
ان تهدى الامور في القريب العاجل
مدينه
قسم كبير من سكان تلك المناطق وايوائهم في
العمر الروسي
الوضع مقلق لكن ليس لحد الخوف الغالبيه
يدركون ان الحرب جاريه ويجب تحمل كل ما
ينتج عنها
القلق على سكان المناطق الحدوديه موجود
فالقذائف لا تميز احدا عن اخر وقد تصيب اي
شخص في الشارع لهذا الوضع بحاجه للتحمل
دون خوف
حصيله الضربات اليوميه على الاقليم خلال
الاسبوع الاخير تتنامى سريعا المنطقه
تتكبد الخسائر الاكبر جراء الصواريخ
وضربات المدفعيه حسب روايه السلطات بينما
تستمر المسيره برشق العبوات الناسفه على
البنيه التحتيه وتنال من شبكات الكهرباء
والاتصال والمياه والغاز والطرقات عبد
الجواد الروشت العربيه
بالغرد لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات